hey guys Ryan right here I've had a few
people tell me about this new Captain
America trailer it's four minutes long
can you believe that [ __ ] that's so
intense everyone's freaking about about
the fact that it's four minutes I'd love
it anyway yeah it's uh it's a four
minute long trailer of Captain America
I'm sure it's gonna be an epic trailer I
love the first few things I saw of this
movie already I saw before Thor the dark
world the exclusive sneak peek at
Captain America the Winter Soldier where
Captain America just [ __ ] up everyone
in the elevator is a pretty sweet scene
and the trailers just keep making it
look better and better and better I
already like it more than the first one
based off the trailer alone I mean you
got Chris Evans in it who seems a lot
more like the badass Captain America
that we really wanted when we saw the
first one I get it it's an origin story
whatever but I think we're gonna get
more of the cap that we wanted he's
gonna bust a cap in the winter soldiers
ass oh I'm clever I'm just looking
forward to seeing Scarlett Johansson
she's so [ __ ] bang worthy I don't
know but you guys ready for minutes of
excitement man
it is a minion Mary setting up their
last payload when Pirates took a magnet
wingman or its other
Garabedian this guy George maximum
casualties all right I'm gonna sweep the
deck and find bad truck man you killed
the engine and wait for instructions run
long see that he likes Captain America
you see the way he was looking at it
scription so did you do anything fun
Saturday night well nothing like joking
about your dead friends
too busy it's got a lot on his plate
mm-hmm Capp Tony no parachute
dude this movies getting my heart
pumping it's just the trailer nice oh
[ __ ] that is more of the kind of [ __ ] I
wanted to see I love the way it's shot
oh yeah the actions just shot a lot
better I love you captain god she's so
sexy they got a comedy back and forth
banter going up
he's a parkour I should take it out also
Kinki damn
ah she's so hot Wow I want to have sex
with her so bad
ouch they could kill someone look at
that ass good that ass yeah there
gotcha
are you ready
jump
a long time I just wanted to do works
right
question what that means anymore
he has inner conflict
sweet and there is the best Tiffany Maki
looks like this [ __ ] in this mood
keep looking god
Oh Oh isn't it yeah I'm definitely high
maxing that [ __ ] that you can get
tickets now okay I'm gonna get tickets
now oh [ __ ] oh damn it I forgot to
deposit my check just my tax refund get
in I I agree I'm just really anxious to
buy tickets right now that that movie
looks [ __ ] awesome okay everything
about it just looks better than the
first one
I mean sure doesn't have as incredible
you know production set design stuff but
I love the tone of this one the way
everything seems shot just seems like
there's more emotional effect going on
like how the action scenes look just
overall what I'm really excited for is
more of Scarlett Johansson's hot ass you
know what I'm really excited for is this
portrayal of Captain America that we're
gonna get you know like yeah I still
have that like American hero thing about
him going on but he's he's ten times
more badass and just off the clips that
we've seen alone like he's really
evolved as a character since Captain
America the First Avenger and then you
got Robert Redford kind of doing like a
Michael Douglas thing about it just this
whole Avengers world is [ __ ] awesome
you know after the Avengers what I was
worried about was will I still be
excited for these standalone movies and
I I don't watch it going on I miss the
other heroes like watching this trailer
I really just want to see this movie
alone not like by myself I'm going to
bring like a really attractive hot girl
with me and if I'm not attracted to you
we leave the movie early it feels like
there's a romantic chemistry thing
happening between Chris Evans and
Scarlett Johansson you know he doesn't
call her a black widow he just goes
Natasha what you doing baby and Anthony
Mackie they just keep showing like
similar clips of what we always see of
Anthony Mackie in these trailers I'm
sure he's gonna be a total badass I have
a feeling he's gonna be like one of the
standout characters the marketing on
this is just brilliant I love how
they're promoting this film it's a
really impressive way to promote it but
it's getting to the point where I'm
thinking they're showing a little too
many Clips now but whatever it's all
cool and stuff but oh gosh did you guys
see those photos of Scarlett Johansson
nude that were not supposed to be
released
maybe I'll spend some time on those bows
before I buy the tickets anyway thank
you guys for suggesting the trailer most
of the time I don't hear about these
shredders so you guys tell me about it
so please continue to suggest more I got
like a whole list of trailers that you
guys have all suggested and I'm planning
on watching all of them and if it's your
first time checking it out if you liked
it subscribe please talk me Chad to be
fun I like I like hearing what everyone
has to say about all these trailers and
stuff and everyone else's anticipations
I like participating in the
conversations and if I look really tired
it's because I've been up editing for a
while now basically the digital
Department had legendary pictures they
saw my trailer reaction for one of the
300 rise of an empire trailers and they
invited me to go to the premiere and
they let me record like so much of what
it was like being there I put together
some of the footage so you know check
that video out why can't I find those
photos of Scarlett Johansson